l'accord est historique la première fois
une entreprise industrielle française
renault signe un texte global pour faire
face à la crise signé par trois
organisations syndicales la cfdt cfe cgc
et force ouvrière ce plan de
compétitivité permettra selon la
direction de faire 400 millions d'euros
d'économies par an soit 300 euros en
moyenne par véhicule
la productivité repartir à la hausse dès
avril prochain
sept cent dix mille véhicules seront
produits par an en france dont 80 milles
des constructeurs partenaires nissan et
peut-être daimler les usines seront
ainsi chargés à 85 % contre 65 %
aujourd'hui
encore faudra-t-il vendre dans un marché
de l'automobile plus que morose
on est en train de revoir toute notre
gamme on lance le véhicule électrique
actuellement on a lancé les véhicules
certes symbolique mais qui montre bien
la volonté de renault d'innover parce
que comme la twizy par exemple et donc
on a besoin d'eux d'innover on a besoin
de conserver les les activités à forte
valeur ajoutée et notamment au niveau de
l'ingénierie pour être à nouveau
compétitif renault supprimera 7500
postes nettes d'emploi d'ici à 2016 les
salaires seront gelés en 2013 et les
ouvriers des usines comme flins verront
leur temps de travail passées de 32
heures à 35 heures en contrepartie la
firme s'engage à ne fermer aucun site ni
à recourir à des plans sociaux